colombia despertó con resaca electoral
después de una noche de espontáneas
celebraciones en las calles tras
conocerse la victoria de la izquierdista
gustavo petro nuevo presidente electo
del país y somos muchos los que creímos
en esto los que teníamos la esperanza
y hoy wow
se hizo realidad junto a su fórmula en
la vicepresidencia francia márquez
enarbolaron la bandera de un cambio por
la paz y la reconciliación de una nación
extremadamente polarizada una
representación que movilizó a millones
de colombianos con la participación
electoral más masiva de su historia al
58 por ciento casi había visto en este
país un cambio que puede ser un cambio
total y favoreciendo en la gente
para mí pero no es todo porque petro es
una persona que está con los pobres no
es orgulloso de trole a todos los pobres
mientras los ricos le quitan a los
pobres las expectativas sobre los
próximos cuatro años del gobierno de
petro son casi tan altas como la
incertidumbre recibo con mucha
incertidumbre puesto que los planes de
gobierno del señor gustavo petro son y
ha sido poco incoherentes
solo pedimos que se respete la
constitución las libertades la libre
empresa porque así es la única forma en
que colombia puede salir adelante pero
el domingo en colombia triunfó el cambio
y tanto los opositores del estero del
m-19 como los servidores de su oponente
el populista rodolfo hernández aceptaron
los resultados no era mi candidato pero
oraré por el orar mucho por él para que
nos lleve a una mejor colombia un cambio
total ahora pero tiene todas las miradas
puestas sobre el primer gobierno de
izquierda